E
GALLAGHER, GOOD TO SEE YOU.
>> SURE.
>> Tucker: WELL, FEW PEOPLE
PREDICTED LAST YEAR THE
CORONAVIRUS WOULD LAST AS LONG
AS THEY HAVE OR THAT THEY WOULD
CAUSES A MUCH DAMAGE TO THE
UNITED STATES AS THEY HAVE.
ONE PERSON WHO DID PREDICT THIS
WAS TEXAS LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
DAN PATRICK.
HE CAME ON THIS SHOW ONE YEAR
AGO THIS WEEK AND ISSUED THE
FOLLOWING WARNING.
>> I'M GOING TO DO EVERYTHING I
CAN TO LIVE.
BUT, YOU KNOW, IF YOU SAID ARE
YOU WILLING TO TAKE A CHANCE,
YOU KNOW, IF I GET SICK, I WILL
GO AND TRY TO GET BETTER.
IF I DON'T, I DON'T.
I'M NOT TRYING TO THINK IN ANY
KIND OF MORBID WAY, TUCKER.
I'M JUST SAYING THAT WE GOT A
CHOICE HERE.
AND WE'RE GOING TO BE IN A TOTAL
COLLAPSE RECESSION, DEPRESSION,
COLLAPSE ON OUR SOCIETY IF THIS
GOES ON ANOTHER SEVERAL MONTH
THERE WON'T BE JOBS TO COME BACK
TO FOR MANY PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: SO FOR SAYING THAT,
OUT LOUD, DAN PATRICK WAS
SAVAGED, HUNDREDS OF PIECES
WRITTEN ABOUT HIM AND HOW HE WAS
INSANE IN IGNORING THE SCIENCE.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENS WHEN YOU SAY
THINGS THAT ARE TRUE.
SO A YEAR AFTER HE SAID THAT WE
THOUGHT IT WOULD BE INTERESTING
TO INVITE LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
DAN PATRICK BACK ON THIS SHOW TO
ASSESS EVERYTHING THAT'S
HAPPENED OVER THE PAST YEAR.
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR DAN PATRICK
GOOD TO SEE YOU DON'T.
THANKS FOR YOUR REMARKS A YEAR
AGO WHICH I THINK HAVE HELD UP
VERY, VERY WELL.
SO, AS YOU LOOK BACK OVER 12
MONTHS, WHAT DO YOU SEE AND
WHAT'S CHANGED?
>> WELL, TUCKER, AMERICA IS
TOTALLY DIFFERENT.
A YEAR AGO TONIGHT, WE WERE A
DIFFERENT AMERICA.
AT THAT POINT IN TIME, TRUMP
LOOKED LIKE A SHOE IN.
WE WERE NOT NEARLY AS RACIALLY
DIVIDED AS WE ARE TODAY.
MOBS HAVE NOT TAKEN OVER THE
STREETS.
THERE WERE NO AUTONOMOUS ZONES.
MOST BUSINESSES FROWNED ON MOST
OF THE WORKFORCE WORKING FROM
HOME.
PARENTS COULDN'T IMAGINE VIRTUAL
SCHOOLS.
AND SOCIALISM DIDN'T HAVE
AMERICA BY THE THROAT.
AND BIDEN AT THAT TIME WAS A
SHAKY CANDIDATE WHO NO ONE KNEW
WHO WOULD WIN THE NOMINATION.
TODAY HE IS A SHAKING PRESIDENT
WHO IS TAKING A WRECKING BALL TO
OUR CONSTITUTION AND TO OUR
LIBERTY TO OUR TO FREEDOM.
IS HE DESTROYING EVERYTHING THAT
THIS COUNTRY WAS BUILT UPON.
YOU KNOW, TUCKER, AFTER WORLD
WAR II, AFTER THE CIVIL WAR,
AFTER 9/11, THOSES WERE DARK
PERIODS IN OUR HISTORY.
DIFFICULT TIMES.
OUR COUNTRY CHANGED, OUR PEOPLE
CHANGED.
BUT WE CAME OUT BETTER FOR IT,
TUCKER.
WE WERE STRONGER.
WE WERE RESILIENT.
WE WERE UNITED.
THIS TIME, THIS DARK PERIOD IS
THE FIRST TIME WE ARE COMING OUT
IN WORSE SHAPE IN A MUCH DIRE
SITUATION BECAUSE OF NOW THIS
CHANGE TO SOCIALISM THAT HAS
HAPPENED IN A BLINK OF AN EYE 12
MONTHS.
>> Tucker: AND AUTHORITARIANISM.
ATTACKING PEOPLE ON THEIR SKIN
COLOR.
THROWING YOUR POLITICAL
OPPONENTS INTO JAIL WHICH THEY
HAVE DONE A LOT.
I NEVER THOUGHT I WOULD SEE IT
HERE.
I HAVE TO ASK YOU WHAT ROLE DO
YOU THINK LOOKING BACK THE COVID
LOCKDOWNS PLAYED IN THESE
CHANGES?
THAT WAS THE FIRST BIG CHANGE.
>> SURE.
WELL, THE OTHER THING THAT I
TALKED ABOUT WITH YOU A YEAR AGO
ON THIS SHOW WE HAVE BEEN ON
WITH YOU SINCE.
A YEAR AGO WHEN WE TALKED ABOUT
THAT I SAID WE HAVE TO BE ABLE
TO DO TWO THINGS.
TAKE CARE OF OUR SENIORS,
PROTECT THEM AND NEW YORK
OBVIOUSLY DIDN'T.
GOVERNOR CUOMO DIDN'T BUT TAKE
CARE OF OUR SENIORS BECAUSE WE
KNEW THEN, TUCKER THE FIRST
MONTH INTO IT THEY WERE THE MOST
VULNERABLE AND SECONDLY EVERYONE
ELSE HAD TO KEEP WORKING.
WE HAD TO KEEP AMERICA GOING.
IF YOU LOOK AT TEXAS AND
FLORIDA, THE TWO STATES THAT
HAVE LED THE WAY OF DOING THAT,
PROTECTING OUR SENIORS THE BEST
WE COULD, AND KEEP OUR COUNTRY
OR OUR STATES OPEN, COMPARE US
TO NEW YORK, WHICH IS A SHELL OF
ITSELF IN THE CITY AND IN THE
STATE, LOOK AT CALIFORNIA, THEY
ARE LOCKED DOWN AND THEIR
NUMBERS ARE NOT MUCH BETTER IN
SOME CASES WORSE THAN OURS IN
TERMS OF THE PANDEMIC.
SO, AMERICA LISTENED TO THOSE
WHO SAID GO HIDE.
HAVE NO HOPE.
LIVE IN FEAR AND THEY CREATED
CHAOS DURING THIS TIME.
AND THAT'S WHAT SOCIALISM FEEDS
UPON.
IT CREATES FEAR AND IT CREATES
CHAOS.
AND TODAY, YOU KNOW, ARE WE ON
THE ROAD TO PERDITION?
THAT WE CAN'T COME BACK FROM?
I KNOW -- I WATCH YOU A LOT.
I KNOW THAT'S HEAVILY ON YOUR
HEART AND IN YOUR MIND.
AND I DON'T KNOW THE ANSWER TO
THAT.
BUT I KNOW THIS.
I BELIEVE IN THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
I BELIEVE UNLIKE THE LEFT WHO
HATES AMERICA AND BREECHES THAT
EVERY DAY, I BELIEVE MOST
AMERICANS LOVE THIS COUNTRY, WE
HAVE ALWAYS DONE BETTER.
WE HAVE LEARNED FROM OUR PAST,
WE ARE A BETTER COUNTRY TODAY
THAN WE WERE 50 YEARS AGO OR 100
YEARS AGO ON MANY OF THESE
ISSUES.
YOU HAVE TALKED ABOUT TONIGHT.
SO I'M COUNTING ON THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE TO TURN BACK.
IT'S REALLY NOT EVEN POLITICS,
TUCKER.
IT'S NOT EVEN REPUBLICAN AND
DEMOCRAT.
WE NEED SOME DEMOCRATS TO STAND
UP.
YOU KNOW, WHEN THEY WANTED TO
IMPEACH ANDREW JOHNSON IN 1868 I
THINK IT WAS, IT WAS EDMOND ROSS
A REPUBLICAN WHO CAST THE VOTE
THAT STOPPED THE IMPEACHMENT.
HE STOOD UP AND AT THAT TIME IT
WAS A VERY INSTRUMENTAL MOMENT
IN OUR COUNTRY NOT TO GO DOWN
THAT ROAD.
WE NEED, WHETHER IT'S MANCHIN OR
SINEMA.
WE NEED DEMOCRATS IN THE SENATE
TO STAND UP FOR AMERICAN VALUES.
LOOK, MANSION REPRESENTS A
REPUBLICAN STATE IN WEST
VIRGINIA.
AND THERE ARE A LOT OF
REPUBLICANS IN ARIZONA ALTHOUGH
IT DIDN'T GO FOR TRUMP THIS
TIME.
THEY NEED TO STAND UP.
WE NEED SOME HEROES RIGHT NOW
THE DEMOCRAT PARTY TO STAND UP
AGAINST THE SOCIALIST LEFTIST
PROGRESSIVE ANGRY PENAL WHO HATE
PEOPLE IN THIS PARTY.
I DON'T THINK ALL DEMOCRATS IN
THIS COUNTRY BELIEF WHAT THEIR
LEADERS ARE SAYING.
WE NEED THEIR PARTY TO STAND UP
AGAINST JOE BIDEN.
>> Tucker: I THINK YOU ARE
EXACTLY RIGHT.
A LOT OF GREAT KEY SEPTEMBER
PEOPLE, GREAT MODERATE PEOPLE IN
COUNTRY IN BOTH PARTIES AND THEY
NEED TO STAND UP RIGHT NOW.
I AGREE WITH THAT.
>> ABSOLUTELY.